hello and welcome to this video game or
Lala the opponent and have played him
before now he only has blitz games
nothing else ever that's around but 3000
of them that's a lot okay may takes a
long while and the early moves in the
petrov let's see what he does
other old main line with deform I'm
actually always quite happy to see that
because it's really rare that people
play it and then have a clue
really I mean and with the Bishop d6
variation yes 6 Bishop d6 if you don't
have a clue with one yeah this is a
typical don't have a clue move and then
black is easily better it's just like
this position is already a little bit
more comfortable for black I mean it's
not much it's not much but white doesn't
have any active idea you can just try to
be solid yeah like you know night to you
three and then and shuffle but it's not
very active the knight on e4 is just a
nice asset to have okay maybe he's
pushing for c4 that would be actually
somewhat active no no see form I wonder
if he plans nah probably not Queen b3 is
a common tactic or a common tactical
mistake the ninety five happens but it's
very unlikely that he's going to going
to play that so anyway let's think about
this a little bit how do we handle this
here with black an interesting way of
playing here is f5 trying to expand even
more maybe go for working side the King
side pawn storm I don't like so much
that he's got
still see form on the radar mm I mean I
can also do can also play on the
queenside
even be five if it's not totally silly
maybe let's do that
it's it's it's a bit odd Mamie
hmm okay it's not very active it's not
easy for white to play this you're just
sitting there with the night stuck on e4
and you don't really easily get rid of
it
maybe that is actually its idea that he
wants to play Knight to d2 but it's not
so clear that this actually works
sometimes I might even have night eggs
f2 in response catching up on the clock
a little bit that's a very typical
scenario for the old mainline oh I
overlooked that idea did not have this
on the radar oh man I don't really want
that that's something that I did not
want to allow that's a bit lame Bishop
was a strong piece on g6 and now it will
be traded
[Music]
hmm it's not really nice and maybe that
was also not great it's night only three
is not really helping him that much I
mean okay I thought that this is a good
structure which is true which is not a
bad porn structure but maybe it is too
too simple too simplistic I think it's
the right word
really there is no tactic here probably
yes because always a check on yet okay
the Rukh only one is unprotected this is
why I was for the moment a little bit a
days there was no tactic yeah there was
always room check see a check now with
the rukon is six there are ideas like 95
or discoveries let's say in general even
95 doesn't really lead to much due to
queenie one but at least that is an idea
the other move that i have on the red a
of course is just queenie aid but he has
to look out for this for example Bishop
f4 95 is a problem and it's definitely a
problem
it's not so easy to make a move and why
this is quite passive
[Music]
so yeah okay threatens made into you can
try I mean it's it's just it's a movie
that you can play quickly and it's not
so clear what what the best response is
yeah he even was the threat actually
this is made into moves yeah okay
sometimes you just have to make a threat
share and it can it can shorten the game
yeah as usual on this this line proves
to be very effective if White has no
particular idea how to handle it
yeah if white in this position does not
play see for now one you can also play
rookie one first then black has choices
but I would go Bishop f5 and then c4 you
should play c4 at some point to make you
to put some pressure on d5 undermine the
center if Y play something yeah like a
non move like f3 then black equalizes
extremely easily and in fact you can
argue that yeah black is easier to play
you know ninety to c6 yeah one one point
is that now some c3 move some c4 move
never works due to this tactic okay it
wasn't maybe a bit quick so now this is
unprotected we had this before here
Indian videos on the channel it's
interesting to see that the engine here
wants to go Knight g5 a move that would
probably not occur to a human player
it's a pretty cool move really and
probably move that equalizes that's
funny
yeah Queen takes is actually a mistake
because now I mean what is black doing
now you
and go back but 96 wins the house at the
end there is made only age it's a
problem you check a line like that you
get mated ok you can don't get made it
I'm sorry right you you lose the size of
material so probably this is just a 95
after taking is probably just a
simplification
okay so c6 Knight to f1 927 yeah and
here it's comfortable but I wasn't quite
sure how to continue the engine wants to
go Knight d2 f6 or Queen f6 yeah you
have a couple of choices it's just it's
comfortable but it's not totally clear
what you should do I even thought f5
could be an option but yeah it's not so
clear what to do after c4 and the engine
confirms that at like c4 for white this
is why I went b5 simply stopping see
form okay so a4 a6 Bishop f1 yeah it's
quite conservative this more so I think
I should be a little bit more
comfortable but Knight h4 it was a bit
of a bummer that this happened I'm
interested though in the position here I
mean here I think it should be roughly
equal which is confirmed by the comp
Queen f3 I found surprising because as
mentioned it just doesn't feel like it
helps yeah you're just setting yourself
up for those things rupees six is the
best means also according to the comp
Queen d1 and cream b8 is actually the
strongest move that's funny
yeah I had the suspicion because I was
thinking I mean I wasn't actually quite
sure what he should play it's not so
easy to say you feel like something like
g3 you can sacrifice I'm very certain
yeah yeah that's true and I can
sacrifice him something something like
that should win somehow not quite sure
how Knight f29 f2 okay yeah I'm
attacking this and this is
big threat so understand overhead that
this wins so that doesn't help and
Bishop III I thought I can just take me
to oh then this is really strong queen
bee age I wasn't quite aware how strong
it was actually because I didn't see
that I'm attacking b2 as well I thought
I had the idea after Bishop me three I
was just thinking exactly that the
second line of the engine I wanted to
play this which is also pretty good it
seems it's - - but it it's kind of a
moot point if you can just take the two
instead and win the pawn a very
important B to Paula that wins wins
everything
essentially yeah it he stumbled into the
mate which was helpful but the position
it seems was already very bad the only
move that seems to defend is rookie -
yeah okay I have to cover have to
somehow which is - - one email Jim where
the engine doesn't give anything
particularly convincing f5 is smooth
which is not quite clear to me what this
does
not sure what the purpose of f5 is the
other move that the engine suggests is
Bishop c7 which is also not quite
obvious to me I mean it's better for
black but it's not it's not a super
straightforward what to do yeah in the
game it was of course a cute maid but
not exactly forced okay guys thanks for
watching